i'm just gonna do it slowly because um i
don't want a big head
it's okay it's weird
look that head is awful oh my god that's
so bad
[Music]
hi i'm sercia ronan and i'm playing
snack wars uk vs ireland with lad bible
we are doing ireland today for obvious
reasons because i am very very irish
oh
nice ease
okay that looks like jemison from here
is it oh no it's bailey's
yeah i mean it says irish on it so
and then is this a scotch yeah
i mean
i kind of feel like i'm half scottish
now so
i think i might get a smack if i don't
choose this but would you like any ice
um
yeah if you've got some
yeah hilarious
oh hello have a wee drum
smokey woody
it's really nice bailey's i'm going to
go for the whiskey though because i
think i look harder if i choose whiskey
can i help my eyes now
yes
this is a packet of potato crisps irish
crisps
i actually never put two and two
together until about three years ago
that they're called potato because
they're made out of potatoes
i'm gonna
do two slices of bread
and you can either
make a little sandwich out of it
and sort of crunch it like that or you
can do what's called a fumble which you
would usually use with um a heel so like
th the last
piece of the loaf but i'll just do this
for today
give it a bit of a crunch
cut it in half
if i do it on a sort of diagonal just
because that's how i was raised
and enjoy
ten out of ten and then this is
trash jelly style cheese and pickle
it looks a bit
dry
looks like there's some
like avocado on there some spinach
and some
like pickled cabbage or something like
that some kind of spiciness a little bit
it's nice but
it's not it's not my crisp sandwich
this is my winner
what's that
old spickled hinge
distinctive english pale ale
i don't like pale ales
i'm just gonna do it slowly because um
i don't want a big head
it's okay it's weird
look that head is awful oh my god that's
so bad what a dreadful head that is i'm
so sorry
i don't yeah i don't love guinness out
of the can
that is nice as well
i
honestly like i'd be shocked if i didn't
choose guinness so
i think i'll probably although they're
they're very nice but i'm gonna i'm
still gonna stick with my own
ah
interesting choice so here we've got i
pronounce it valley malou i don't know
if it's bali mallow or belly blue but i
always say bali malu and it comes from
cork which is my favorite county in
ireland sorry dublin but it is
um it's delicious and i've grown up
having um this relish on
everything my mom puts it on everything
what do you have it with normally have
it with like cheese you'd have it on on
a sandwich
a bit of cheese and ham and then what is
this
the gentleman's relish that sounds rude
perfect spread on chose crackers or
blinis yeah that's so much more british
than
everything you just put it on a bit of
bread and cheese
i i will say
i don't want to like you know upset
anyone but i do really like the
packaging of this
i love bali malay
i love cork i love ireland oh i do like
the packaging for this oh this looks
lovely
it doesn't smell so nice though
it kind of looks like a pate or
something
i'll try this one first
i don't know what that is yeah it's kind
of it's nice i feel like they'd actually
go really well together it's very salty
though what do you think it is
oh i have to guess what it is
it tastes like it's got capers in it or
something
i don't know it's or like anchovies yes
it's got anchovies in it yeah i do like
anchovies this is spicy anchovy paste
yeah it's nice
i think that'd be nice and like
maybe a pasta or something
i will say these actually go really well
together
because valuable is very sweet it was
quite nice to just wash that down with
the belly below
um
i'm gonna have to pick the value my lube
i grew up with it
i know it
it never lets me down but i do really
like the gentleman's relish as well
[Music]
minis
jeremy jojo minis these are irish
these are from the uk
but i've always loved
jammie dodgers
and mallows
oh they're very small
i like small things
um
i love your jerky georgia
look how pretty these are
they're so pretty
i mean they're both very very pretty
[Music]
i love these i love them i like that
there's different
consistencies textures
it's just the right amount of sweetness
the coconut is really refreshing
it's more cakey than biscuity which i
like
so these win for me this time
island one yay ireland one
i'm irish
i love this game
[Laughter]
jelly tots right yeah like kids how
would you say that in a lilting english
accent jelly tots jelly tops
[Laughter]
i love how suddenly you said it perfect
jelly